cleared of breaking the ministerial code
by an
independent inquiry nicola sturgeon said
her focus
was on the pandemic my thoughts today
one year on from the country going into
lockdown
are with the almost 10 000 families
across the country who've lost a loved
one
to the coronavirus pandemic a moment of
reflection on the anniversary of
lockdown
the first minister later said she looked
forward to a new beginning
the toxic atmosphere that has infected
this chamber in recent months will give
way i hope
to the fresh air of an election
and i hope that the fresh air will bring
with it a rigorous
and positive debate not just about
personalities
but about the kind of country we want to
be
the scottish national party is hoping
the parliamentary election in six weeks
time
will deliver an outright majority
pointing the way
to independence and beyond
let's create that roadmap that allows us
as we come out of covet
to have that independence referendum to
be able to have that discussion
about completing the powers of the
scottish parliament about having
the opportunity to get back into europe
but the unseemly breakdown in relations
between sturgeon and her predecessor as
party leader alex salmond
over the scottish government's
mishandling of sexual misconduct
allegations
may have dented snp hopes and some
voters may take a dim view of the
finding by a parliamentary committee
that sturgeon gave misleading evidence
probably true that support for the smp
is now running it about three points
lower than it was in january um
that's not a lot but it if it were to
persist it could make the difference
between the snp guessing an overall
majority in the hollywood parliament
which now everybody seems to accept
is the crucial target to what might
happen to independence thereafter
between
achieving that target and not doing so
so a majority for the scottish national
party is by no means guaranteed
but it is vital for the independence
cause the prime minister boris johnson
has ruled out granting scotland another
referendum so soon after the first in
2014
but a big win for the snp would be a
powerful electoral mandate
that westminster may find hard to ignore
exonerated but not entirely unblemished
nicola sturgeon survived a vote of no
confidence called by johnson's
conservatives
the opposition here in scotland as the
election campaign begins this week
there's little more they can do to stop
her jonah hull al jazeera edinburgh